oh would you guys like an unhelpful
advice question yes please
yeah go ahead on hopeful advice with
bobby and kalyla
hey tiger belly my name is chris i am a
24 year old law student and i live with
my girlfriend and her family in their
house when i was noted
notified that school would be all over
zoom i decided to live here so i could
save money and not have to pay for an
apartment closer to campus
the problem is my girlfriend developed a
gluten intolerance over the past few
months and she constantly burps
it sounds silly but it's very
distracting has even impacted our
relationship
my desk is inside our bedroom and the
constant burping makes it very hard to
concentrate
on what i'm reading she's transitioning
over to gluten-free diet hopefully that
helps
what should i do in the meantime all the
libraries are closed my girlfriend can't
stop burping the house is small so i
can't really move to another room i
really need to have a quiet area where i
can focus
hopefully you all can help me i love the
podcast
so he's he's taking classes online well
they're stuck
they're quarantining together and so
basically
they're stuck in a home together and his
girlfriend
has a gluten intolerance right no i get
it so um there's something
they invented called headphones noise
cancelling right
you're on zoom you can't put headphones
in and take the class that way
yeah that's true that's a good point
what the [ __ ] is this about then yeah
what about when they're in just in bed
together and she just is burping burping
burping but that
has nothing to do with them you did deal
with that it's like you know i have to
deal with some of your [ __ ] like what
your wet feet
wait no does that affect your livelihood
no i'm just saying it's like
you know she has a she's wet that sounds
so wrong she's
wet yeah yeah yeah she's that wet ass
feet you know
um i mean you know there are certain
things that people like i i'm sure
obviously i have a lot of things you
mean that you have to deal with
can you give us one thing that you've
had to deal with but you found a
solution
i haven't found any solutions okay yeah
yeah there have been no solutions there
is no house only misery
misery um um here's what i think well
actually
bobby should speak to this because you
are very sensitive about hearing people
burp
it's funny because you burp but when you
hear other people burp you feel grossed
out no i don't
yeah you do you every time i even the
tiniest little burp for me you're like
ew
you don't like burp and you don't like
vomit yeah i don't like vomit
that that that that for sure i hate
vomit do you gag when you see it not a
vomit i i'd rather
poo i rather have than vomit like in the
house he cleans the poo
i won't vom clean vomit he will he
refuses to clean vomiting i don't like
it
you know poo is easy you know um
yeah because i don't vomit you've never
vomited there's two types of people
there are
diarrhea people or there are vomiters
yeah yeah i'm a diarrhea man i'm a
diarrhea man
all day long 24 7. you know i mean but
for life
diarrhea have you ever seen me vomit i
have never seen you vomit in all this
eight years yeah really never no i just
don't do it
i've gagged you don't even have a gag
reflex you can't really yeah yeah
whoa i cough you're wasted on this
heterosexual
relationship you'd make a
you'd make a man so happy with your lack
of goggles
i don't know if i can come up with this
big papaya is over at patreon
kyle snuffer
[Music]
bonjour oh you're supposed to do a
shippery thing